[Music] It's so
nostalgic
Bash On
this planet where there's nothing
left to do, we can't create new ecological dynamism plants that create everything necessary for humankind from scratch,
so every city is under strict control.
It's mine, no
, it's us The
plant won't be taken away, it's connecting the lives of the people in this town
Whose side are
you on?
If it's my twin brother,
what is the reason why he's aiming for
the plant?  No matter how
long it takes No matter how long it takes Watch them die
You haven't changed a thing since then It's
each other Let's
free the
plants from the evil humans
[Music]
[Applause]
Find a way to save everyone  No humans,
no plants
[music]